you mentioned cus cust mod legendary
trainer and you also mentioned it turned
out he really cared about you in the
book you write about a testimony he gave
I was hoping I could read it cuz it
speaks to your character it speaks to
his it's just powerful the testimony
goes your honor I realize you might not
know much about me but I've spent my
whole life developing young men as a
boxing manager I trained two world
champions heavyweight champion Floyd
Patterson and light heavyweight champion
Jose
Torres I've also helped a lot of other
young boys straighten out their lives
and build character I know things about
Teddy Atlas this court doesn't know
things you won't find on his arrest
record this boy has character he has
loyalty he'll hurt himself before he'll
let down a friend these qualities are
rare and they shouldn't be lost he's
made mistakes we've all made mistakes
but I've come to know this boy and if we
lose him we'll be losing someone who
could help a lot of people please don't
take this young boy's future away he
could be someone special let's not lose
him
please those are powerful words from a
powerful man uh what have you learned
about life from from uh Mr
custado
he gave me a quote and he drilled into
my head I became his guy you know he
loved me I loved
him he he said to
me
Teddy no matter what a man says is what
he does in the end that he intended to
do all
along that's what I learned from
cus rest of it is BS
and
um a lot of people
um say things you just have to give them
a minute
to let them show you
eventually what they really meant by
it I also learned from him that
uh everyone's afraid
cu's way of saying another great saying
you'll get kick out of this uh anyone
who's in a situation where fear should
be prevalent where fear is actually
necessary to survive the situation
anyone who says that they're not afraid
they're one of two things they're either
a liar or they should go to a doctor
find out what the freak's wrong with
them he was right about
that you know we live in a a taboo
Society where that word to a certain
extent is taboo because it invokes
weakness you know we we
are we are just layers of what we saw
and learned since we were kids we all
are we're products of those layers I
learned that on my own well feel
somehow at the end of the day
um you know
fear people will find their way of
avoiding that term so they use the word
anxiety they use the word you know
butterflies apprehension you know a
million different right words I find all
those other words to be cousins of fear
and and fear fear causes a lot of things
in life it it causes a lot of problems
uh and and it also solves a lot of
problems without it uh we couldn't be
great if we are great if we ever have a
chance to be great um or at least to
Aspire to be great how how does Fear
connect to Greatness that's a that's a
profound statement without fear we
wouldn't be able to be
great yeah you couldn't be great without
fear because fear allows you to be
Brave the most important word for me in
this whole you know conversation right
neighborhood would be
selfishness uh it allows you to be for a
moment less
selfish one of the things I learned I
guess partly on my
own everyone thinks my greatest teacher
was cus he was a great teacher but
Mentor my greatest teacher was my father
the one who never
talked and um I realized um one of the
things to be better towards
great um is if you can
be submit less than we submit see one of
the things that I'm afraid of one of the
things I was always
quitting and my business it's kind of
not a good thing MH every business I
think yours yours is just more uh clear
yeah it it hurts more
[Laughter]
and in the moment at least yeah in the
moment but you're right 100% because
some things Hur for a long time
afterwards and um something like regret
regret is the worst thing in the world
because it's a solitary
sentence and and man oh man that's a
powerful phrase regret is a solitary
sentence so boy I you're full of good
lines you know it wasn't easy to uh to
to accumulate them it it was a little
bit hurtful but so uh submit less
because we submit every day and if we
can get to a place where we submiss or
compromise ourselves
less we get to a better place you know
again one of the one of the words for me
that attaches to things that give you
that wind up hurting you in life and
have hurt me in life uh one of those
boogey men words is the word of
convenience that's attach to everything
you know PE people
people disappoint you not because they
want to disappoint you or let you down
or betray you because they want to
betray you they do it because it's more
convenient to do than than the other
thing